- [Narrator] Sweden's largest
internet service provider
is located somewhere you might not expect,
below 100 feet of bedrock
in a former nuclear bunker.
The Pionen Data Center
houses some of the most
sensitive information in the world,
which once included Wikileaks servers.
They can help protect
their clients information
under Sweden's Free Speech Act.
Inside engines intended to
be for German submarines
are used as backup generators.
The design and style is the
work of CEO, Jon Karlung,
who took inspiration
from his love of films.
He says that the choice
to put plants in the caves
was to capture the
computer meets plants vibe
of sci-fi films from the ’70's.
The plants are kept alive by grow lights.
The center has simulated daylight
and the waterfall,
well that's just for fun.
And while it may look like a
villain's lair from James Bond
you won't find Goldfinger here,
just the 15 senior technical
staff who run the servers.